[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
it was round five of the summer classic
here in st. Louis while a cobia and
Dhirubhai Lee was the key matchup the
pair agreed to a draw before our show
into air but seeps winning streak is
over every other group a showdown was
decisive including Alexander in jij
handing Sam seve on his first defeat
Group B standings changed only slightly
since the only win came from Josh
Friedel over Sidhu a cassava free Dell
enters a five way log jam for second
place coverage of Round six starts now
twenty international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as us chess champs
comm presents the first ever summer
chess classic
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the st. Louis
chess club studio and around six of 2018
summer chess classic I am women
grandmaster Katerina I am Torah and I'm
joined by international master Eric
Rosen now we have many interesting games
going on right now but yesterday was a
very decisive day for a group a so let's
review yesterday's results that's right
we have a very bloody day yesterday in
Group A for decisive games
Benjamin Bach Alexander and Judge
Jeffrey Zhang Andhra Natyam abaya of all
winning their games the two leaders of
Group A Barra Cobian and received our
Bailey agreed to a relatively peaceful
draw and this brings us to standings and
we can see if a thief Tara Bailey is
still in clear first four and a half out
of five points that's a very strong
start given it's such a strong field
exactly and what happened in Group B
yesterday we had many results resulting
in draw only Josh Vidal warned against
Daenerys adore cassava and all other
players agreed on draw
now that the stadium's did not change
too much we still have the leader polish
grandmaster cameo dragon with three and
health points out of five and five way
tie for the second place we're at GG
Allin Miranda Sergey Marcinko Josh
Rydell Alejandro Ramirez and Andres Duke
open all have three points and let's
take a look at the term in format we
have two groups of course 210 player
around robins
with a time control of 90 minutes for 40
moves plus 30 minutes for the remainder
of the game and of course a 30 second
increments starting from move one and
let's remember that players are not
allowed to agree on a draw before move
30 this brings us to schedule we have
all around starting at 1:00 p.m. Central
time only the last round starts at 11:00
a.m.
now if there is a fight if there is a
tie for the first spot players will have
a playoff starting at 5 p.m. and let's
take a look at the pairings for today in
Group A we have a bunch of exciting
matchups
Benjamin balk against tournament leader
of a thief char Bailey
Peter / Houska against four
jacobian euros Arabic against her not
you mabye of the two youngsters in the
field Sam seven the playing Jeffrey Jean
that's already a match up which is
heating up and Daniel Friedman drawing
Alexander in ditch in what was a very
quick game and Baldwin is our key
matchup
Benjamin bhaag against Vasa Dhirubhai
Lee vas see if only having a draw
yesterday otherwise perfect score
Benjamin box scoring a first point
yesterday so let's go and at the ball
let's glance at the board and see what's
happening yeah and I have to say this
game is a bit reminiscent of a thief's
game against version of Kobe and it
seemed like what was a relatively Josh
opening but if we take a look at the
current position white is up upon so
maybe there's something for Benjamin to
play for do you think any winning
chances for whites now it looks always
promising to have some material up but
we have to think how white can continue
how the king can help maybe the pawn to
promote I think it's not that easy for
what to find the way for looking to get
to the Queen side noting that you know
we have a double pawn there and we also
have to be careful about not losing all
the points on the Kings side that's
right and I like what was Seif has done
putting the rook on a very active square
a3 not only is it defending against the
past a pawn but it's also creating some
issues for whites along along the ranks
we might see a potential move like rook
a to cutting the White King off
completely and I was actually joking
earlier that maybe black has a mating
idea with was simply pushing the pawns
pawn on e5 on h5 and if Black gets maybe
five moves in a row it could end in
checkmate yes but unfortunately probably
there are no five moves in a row for
black we will go back to this game to
see what's happening but let's see what
about Group B what is their pairings we
already have a result for the game
Daenerys aduba Kesava who won against
Alejandro Ramirez and there is a draw
between Sergei Mateo and Andres to cope
in Carmel dragon is still playing Gigi
Alomar and a Tata
Abraham Ian is playing with Vladimir
bellows and Josh free del is playing
against Robert Alcazar Ian and the key
matchup of today is tournament leader of
Group B camille dragon
against JJ I'll ignore Andy who has not
lost a game we should note actually
either neither of these players have
lost a game so far this tournament so or
probably gonna expect a very very
hard-fought battle so let's see what's
happening there now we can see JJ
thinking with with Kamil away from the
board currently if we take a look at the
current position it seems like both
sides have very ugly and bizarre pawn
structure yes before we were saying how
the bishop on d7 is kind of useless not
having anything to do but suddenly maybe
it has the open diagonal it can do
something what do you what do you think
hearing about the pawns on D 3 e to f4
I mean they are Center pawns and
sometimes I mean you you do want to
control the center in chess so white has
white does have more potential to
control the center we might see some
central advance I think this last move
that was played Bishop to c1 not only is
it defending the pawn on b2 but perhaps
it's getting ready for some center lunge
like Pawnee 4 and perhaps pawn f5 and I
do like what what Camille is doing in
this position going for the expansion
and maybe white is one playing for some
advantage here I have to agree and camel
is the leader so he wants to win the
tournament let's see what are the prizes
what the players are fighting for that's
right we have a very generous prize fund
for group a 20 through 22 thousand
dollars up for grabs with a $6,000
first-place prize lots of money on the
line absolutely and the group B also has
a big prize fund the total of $40,000
and the first price is $4,000 right so
lots of money to play for I'm sure
especially towards the end of the
tournament players will be fighting for
every single half point I agree so let's
see what is happening
maybe interim and a yeah there's
actually a really interesting position
between Sam 7 and Jeffrey's drawing I do
want to go back and show the opening
just because it was so unusual
Savion is sometimes known for being a
bit creative in the opening and this
game he really showed his creativity we
had what started as a close Sicilian 93
Sicilian which is one of my favorite
openings to play as whites but then we
see the very unusual pawn d4
it's it's maybe combining ideas of the
open Sicilian and closest alien usually
we see white preparing d4 with a move
like Knight f3 but in this case after a
pawn take T for Queen take T for it's a
bit unusual for white to bring out the
Queen so early
yes and what's even more unusual is this
this is the following idea that Sam
Savion decided to play b3 I mean have
you ever played b3 in such an opening
Eric I mean I'm not the type of player
into play b3 I like more classical and
kind of the standard chess but I do have
to admire the idea which I mean it's
very simple play Bishop b2 and have some
scope along the long diagonal if we do
see how the game develops after Queen d2
Jeffery appears to have employed
somewhat of a dragon setup with Bishop
g7 so we can see from the very beginning
a lot of tension between the two darts
for bishops and what happened in the
middle game black Castle kingside which
leads us to position with opposites like
castling which as we've seen from
previous games these positions can be
very very sharp and tactical and we need
to know that Geoffrey is a very active
player very strong Grandmaster maybe
some savvy and just wanted to play
something different something offshore
that's not trendy now that's true I mean
it's not a bad strategy to have some
surprise value in the opening even if
it's not the the most reliable line if
you can get your opponent out of their
comfort zone especially someone like
Geoffrey who's very well prepared in the
opening so what if we fast forward to
the current position yeah a lot of
craziness happened
we shouldn't note this this pawn
sacrifice Pawnee for which actually
turned into an exchange sacrifice and I
take a four was met with rook take a
four trying to just bust open the Queen
side so Geoffrey seems to be going all
out for a win here like Queen b6 and we
can see the King on b1 not the safest of
pieces with both the Queen on b6 and so
this Bishop on b7 it appeared the threat
was it was a very venomous and I take e4
here which would threaten both mate and
the Queen on g2 so I like the way Sam
responded with Bishop b5 just creating a
post for the bishop
and then he reinforced the bishop with
c4 the idea of c4 is reinforcing the
bishop on b5 but also maybe the Queen
defending the b2 so there's no issue
happening with the diagonal and the
bishop on g7 maybe attacking it in
future that's right and now it's going
to be up to Jeffrey if he can actually
prove compensation for sacking the
exchange 98 doesn't seem like the most
impressive move in the position and
let's zoom forward to the current
position Sam optimizing his pieces Queen
c3 and bishop on d4 I do like the setup
from White's the bishops do got traded
on b5 and actually Sam thought to fix
his pawn structure so no more double-a
pawns for whites but Knight takes e4 was
played and Bishop take g7 brings us to
the current position where it seems like
blacks should probably recapture with
the Knights any thoughts about this this
situation is always tricky when the King
is exposed knight on c4 there is some
cooperation with the rook like rook a3
coming up maybe the night from f6 to d7
what is happening here I mean the blood
has to recapture with Knight I don't I
mean we can see Geoffrey is taking his
time Sam is not at the board so maybe
nine take g7 isn't the only new that
he's considering maybe 93 intermediate
mover we are giving a check and forcing
the King to go somewhere yeah 93
definitely one possibility I was
actually thinking about rookie a3 - why
not
improve the rook attack the Queen so
seems like some interesting option
options for Geoffrey and it might be
might be a little bit dangerous for
white given that there is not much
shelter around the white king and black
has some decent potential to it I also
need to note that Geoffrey only has 12
minutes for 20 more moves to make that's
a really good point and it's not it's
not easy being low on time in the
position is getting very complicated so
maybe this goes back to Sam's opening
strategy where he wanted to make
Geoffrey used a lot of time at the
beginning of the game so he would have
more time for some later complex
situation I agree and I like White's
position I think it's still very solid
and
we are exchanged up Blake has to prove
that there is something for for the
exchange that's very true so let's keep
an eye on this game but let's move on to
another battle taking place a game that
was catching my eye but just ended in
the draw is the fight between Daniel
Friedman and Alexander in judge we were
taking a look at this game earlier and
it seemed like white had some some sort
of pole in the position maybe we can go
back a few moves and see what happened
because right around here this move rook
c7 I move 21 it seemed like White was
completely dominating the C file but
sometimes positions like this with where
there's so much material that's already
off the board it's not easy to make
progress yes and we also have to know
the bishop on e2 I mean the bishop is so
sad it doesn't have any squares really
where to go if there was a knight maybe
we could jump somewhere around pick the
squares but the bishop is tied to light
squares and these squares are just
blogged by blacks pawns
that's right sometimes when your bishop
is on the same color pawns as your
opponent the bishop is just a lot more
easily restricted in this case there's
not a clear home for the white bishop
meanwhile blacks Bishop I like
controlling the b1 h7 diagonal if we go
forward to see what happened white does
dominate the C file with both rooks but
it doesn't seem clear how white actually
makes progress in this position and I do
like what Alexander in judge did just
going for the trade of rooks rook eight
to b7 and it seems like White's
really can't avoid the trade and they
just went for the perpetual in in this
position I was actually thinking if if
black is forced to to go for perpetual
or if maybe black and try to play for
for some advantage but the issue is that
the bishop on g6 cannot be improved I
mean I wish I could go to D 3 and C 4
but there is really no space to to go
with the bishop yeah it seems it seems
difficult for both sides and I feel like
a draw is a very fair result we're
probably both players are are happy to
have a quick game maybe especially in
the later rounds of the tournament you
don't want to be devoting so much energy
to every single game and it's not not
such a bad thing to have a quick game
like this I agree so what if we go to
the tournament B we saw that maybe Tata
Abraham Ian had an advantage against
Vladimir Bella so what is happening
there that's right that was a very crazy
position earlier Tata of going for the
King side attack she did break through
with her Queen let's actually go back to
that moment cuz didn't take a look
earlier but it seemed like she was she
was able to lunge her H pawn forward on
the H file on move 19 she played the
very standard pawn h5 going for going
for some active play with her rook on h1
f6 was played and Queen h6 and I do
admire the way she's playing it seems
like she's being very resourceful with
her pieces right f8h file did open and
her Knights coming from the other
direction onto d5 and it seems like
black is the one who is trying to just
stay alive in this position and I have
to know that F is my friend she's my
teammate from the u.s. women's Olympic
team so I know she likes aggressive play
she likes to attack so I think she's
very happy with her position that's a
good point
it's always nice if you can get a
position that really suits your style
and in this case I mean black seems to
be almost collapsing I'm surprised that
the game is still going given that I
mean it seems like white should have
some sort of meaning mating idea here we
should note this Nayana fates doing a
very nice job keeping keeping some key
squares defended especially this h7
Square which can't be accessed by the
right by the white rook right away so
thought to have played the very mini
compositional King b1 maybe following
the advice of Grandmaster Ben triangle
who says always play King b1 especially
when you're not sure what to do so
what's there is a very nice idea instead
of Bishop d3 why would love to put the
bishop on the a2 GA diagram so it could
attack the King but the problem is that
what has to be also careful about about
her King so let's say white X C takes b5
they may be there will be some issue
like 94 and we can see box counter play
can come very quickly I really like that
idea from black just going for the going
for the attack along the sea
and of course whites whites knight is
pinned to the c1 square at night 84
would end in the media checkmate
so I'm sure Tata doesn't want to open up
too many lines on the side where her
opponent King where her King is is
currently staying so that's why she went
to Bishop e3 instead Bishop d3 was
played in 97 let's get to the current
position and try and figure out what
what's happening the rooks are getting
traded and Knight g4 is played brings us
to the current position where it seems
like White has everything to play for
potential for the night to come to h6
and let's keep in mind the bishop has a
very simple maneuver Bishop to C 2 into
83-14 says to the top yes and we have to
know that night on f8 is actually very
strong really defending the king so I
I'm thinking what if black plays let's
say queen c6 what if I simply defend six
square and now want my route from aah to
get into play yeah maybe there's not a
knockout flow in this position but I can
imagine
Tata if we'll just be happy improving
her pieces further a move like Bishop C
to bring the bishop to to b3 and
sometimes if you can't cross your
opponent right away you just want to
keep adding pressure adding pressure
until you you get that last straw which
which breaks the camel's back yes I
agree so let's let's move on to the next
game what is the leader of the group the
Cameo dragged on doing with JJ Ali
morandi the center looks amazing and
this is our key matchup of today we were
we did glance with this game earlier and
now we see this pawn expansion with
Pawnee for I'm sure it looks like white
is going for the the further expansion
with pawn f5 and we should note that
there are off the cart bishops in this
position so I do like what white is
doing putting the pawns on light squares
making sure that the bishop can find
perhaps about a square in this position
and also restricting blacks very
depressing bishop on d7 and now it's I
mean it's very difficult here to to find
what you do with black because the pawns
are defending all squares and
controlling important
important squares and black doesn't have
a way to really go on attack the white
king it doesn't have a way to try to
improve maybe his pawns and go for some
kind of promotion I think this is a very
difficult situation for JJ I would not
be happy being black in this position we
can see JJ sitting there at the board
kamil dragon away from the board that's
usually a sign that Camille is probably
comfortable here and this is this is a
common idea in chess if you control the
center if you control a lob he squares
it's just difficult for the opponent to
find activity and sometimes situations
like this could cause black - maybe
blunder or it's not entirely clear what
to do yes I often tell my students just
put your piece if you know pieces in a
good position and then let your opponent
make a mistake I think we just witnessed
something it looks like JJ did reach out
his hand it looked like he touched his
queen but then he brought his hand back
and he's continuing to think 626 was
played yes okay so maybe there's not too
much
synchronization here at the Queen e6
played it just disappeared you are
correct
it disappears ah I wonder if he tricked
the GGT board he probably played Queen
e6 doom hit the clock moved the Queen
back to g6 and then he changed his mind
to play Queen f7 plays yes you don't see
that too often with very strong players
making a move not letting go and then
changing their mind and it says
something about the player how he feels
about the position I mean he has 20
minutes so it's not like he has to
resign immediately but he's still
insecure in really deciding deciding
which move to make that's true and I
usually see this among among kids where
they they want to reach out their hands
and make a move and I usually tell my
students chess is played with the mind
and not with the hands and you should
really be absolutely sure what you want
to move before you even reach out your
hand
but even sometimes the top players will
will go against his principle so what if
we move on to the game of Josh Friedel
against Robert oka sorry on I thought
Josh made an amazing move with g5
claiming some advantage but
sure if this is the case right now right
let's try and go back and find that find
the moment where Josh did play g5 we see
a somewhat imbalanced position where
White has just the the Queens did get
traded on e3 leaving light with maybe
not the happiest pawn structure on the a
file but if we go forward a very
aggressive move g5 appears to be a pawn
sacrifice that's a very nice idea that
if you at least I thought it if you take
I can go with something like F 6 because
the g7 is defending the knight on 86 so
we do have to be careful as black of
capturing the second pawn but it did not
happen I wonder why so Josh actually had
a different idea in the position given
the pawn and six is no longer no longer
controlling this a five square Josh very
simply played 95 which is a very nice
positional move also comes with the
tactical threats perhaps considering
roof take h6 followed by Knight take F 7
so this prompted black to play rook f8
and if we look Josh is currently down
upon but black spawns on the G file are
quite weak but what do you think would
happen if I played f6 instead of 90s 95
mmm so you're saying f6 may be
potentially stronger or at least another
option for whites this does look
interesting because of the pawn on g7
can't move I mean I want to take the
pawn or I want just to go for promotion
with the pawn I'm actually curious about
this maybe a move like rook rook g8
possible going for a pure defense but
now I have 97 possibly high 97 simple
fork I thought I had saw a very
interesting line so f6 Bishop takes g6
bishop days g6 now something like night
sorry no blacks under pressure the pawn
is attacked on g7 the night under
constant eye from the rook on each one
this does not seem pleasant for black
what scannable we know we have very
strong grandmasters and they have did a
lot of time I mean they're 20 minutes so
I'm sure Josh thought about this move f6
we should know we're not using an engine
this is a type of moment where it may be
a supercomputer like stock fish could
just spit out an answer but for us mere
humans we we have to analyze on our own
so this is maybe a question for Josh
after the game if we can get them in the
studio okay so let's move on let's see
what happen in game soap so 95 was
played rukka fades rook g1 going trying
to win back at least one pawn along the
G file g4 played and then white did win
back the pawn black traded off
perhaps the passive night on h6 and
let's get four or go forward to the
current position black bringing the King
in and perhaps maneuvering the Knight to
d6 it is currently Josh's move and
materials equal but I I would probably
have to favor black in this position
just given the the ugliness of whites
pawn structure I mean every single pawn
is isolated and especially you will get
your cup of Wang Kai Knight only six
yeah I mean I think I've mentioned this
most days but and a lot of Queens gambit
declined positions is Mike coming to d6
just such a nice positional piece
combining very well with blacks pawn
structure controlling a lot of key
center squares and in this case I would
have to take back I mean unless there is
something we are completely missing I
think black is the one who is pushing
for for advantage here that's right and
we can see Josh they're biting his nails
seems a bit nervous yeah well let's you
we will wait what he figures out here
and let's move on maybe to go back to
tournament a we didn't see what is yaro
share abou doing in a game against Rena
Gemma buyeth the arrow lost yesterday a
tough loss
Renato scored his first point that's
right and we can see I mean Renaud seems
to have a lot of pressure on
the half-open efile queenie 5 having
just been played avoiding the Queen
trade and I always tell my students if
your pawns King is less safe or if
you're the one attacking keep Queens on
the board this is exactly what we're not
did and in this position that seems like
there might be some ideas of queen bee -
trying to infiltrate White's territory
so Yara responded with rooks ce-1 making
sure that when queen bee to happen
he happens he has Ruki - yeah that's a
nice idea I do like this move rook ce-1
just making sure the position is held
together there's not too much invasion
for black and I I would be curious what
black is doing next because it seems
like if we just look at blacks pieces
are all on relatively nice squares and
positions like this you either want to
optimize your pieces further or look for
some kind of break through some kind of
tactical breakthrough and it's not clear
how back is continuing here the issue
that I see here is that Renaud has only
ten minutes less than ten minutes for 14
moves and he just played Queen c7 simply
retreating the Queen to defend the pawn
on a five that is being attacked by the
Queen that's right actually we should
mention that white was attacking both of
these pawns which are not defended so
Queen c7 may be a necessary move and we
can also note that white does have some
potential to maybe cause some issues for
black in this position if we imagine
let's say white goes for maybe the solid
rook to e2 and then someday bring the
rook to to the C file to try and try and
create some pressure against this
backward c6 pawn and when we see the
knight on f6 we have a perfect pawn on
f3 for white who is blocking this night
or on going exactly to d square as chief
for and a4 that's very true
but we should keep in mind that White's
rook on h1 is tied down to defending the
h2 pawn so it might take some some
safety moves for a white to fully defend
everything in the position we might see
rookie two coming followed by g3 and
then swinging the rook over and I mean
for a black maybe it's a question you
bring out the good points of how the
night can actually get to a better
square in the game and the arrow has
about 20 minutes so we will let him
think we have a result from group a
where Benjamin bug true against passive
durable a that would be predicted Uruk
and game and the game looked kind of
trollish it's true we can see neither
player at the board there and it seemed
like white had no way of making progress
in the position the rook on a to fully
cutting off the King on f3 and with this
last move rook g8 I mean why it's just
not making progress after something like
King r7 the rook would have to return to
AIDS this is just a dead draw exactly so
let's go to a game of Sam Sammy and
again Geoffrey showing there is some
crazy things happening black did not
recapture a bishop on g7 and goats went
for even more variations that yeah we
were discussing this position earlier we
assumed that Knight take g7 should be
played Queen c5 was played between which
both of us didn't consider I'm curious
if there's a tactical threat with this
move may be very simply I mean take b5
as a threat so white played rook to d5
and then another counter-attack Knight
to a3 King a 1 and then Queen f2 leads
us to a very bizarre position with
pieces scattered all over the board I
mean right now white is broke up so
black has to make sure that there is
something but we have to know that the
bishop on g7 is hanging tonight on E 2
is hanging so most likely who black will
be able to get at least one of those
light pieces but it still does not look
like it should be enough I mean I've
these are positions which I don't like
to play I know Sam Savion excels in
these positions which are incredibly
crazy and I know that because I played
Sam 7 a few years ago at the Chicago
open and he destroyed me as as black in
22 moves I really had no chance and
that's because he steered the game into
a very tactical position which he was
just much better equipped for
so what if white plays here are
something on you Bishop eight-six I like
to keep the bishop on board to make sure
I mean I can give up the night but the
bishop I think it's very strong by
controlling all the dark squares
yeah the bishop could be effective on h6
controlling the c1 h6 diagonal and also
perhaps paralyzing the not an e a given
that Queen g7 is always something for
for black to worry about in the position
if Bishop h6 is played I think we can
expect Queen take e2 and then that's a
question can black continue the attack
there is some pressure against the a to
pawn given the Queen on e2 and the rook
on 8 both having some some target to
attack so if I go something like in a
rookie to a rook c1 not sure which one
to go so maybe rook t2 is logical
hitting the Queen but this leaves the
pawn on d5 hanging maybe black and try
and scoop up more material and now I
finally go with my rook c1 developing
the last piece that didn't make a move
in this game I mean I make change up
that's very true white is up the
exchange if we're counting pawns we can
see black does have one pawn for the
exchange
but with Queens on the board and such a
sharp position and such lack of safety
for the white king you would think that
Geoffrey has at least some conversation
I agree and we will shortly have a guest
in the studio but let's before that
let's see what's happening we didn't see
the game between Peter Prohaska and
Verico beyond it's right it's somewhat
of a dry position peter Prohaska perhaps
i don't know it seems like maybe he's
okay accepting a draw here but white
should be having the upper hand here
just given the activity of the rooks
both on b2 and c7 we can note that b6
pawn very weak and white has one very
nice plan Island on the King side yes
and we always talk about the rook and
games and how they are tricky even if
let's say white has pawn app but here
why doesn't have a phone app we know
that the material is equal the poem b6
looks like it's
extra but White has this pawn which is
still which is still here which is the
opposite so material is equal and now
whenever the black tries to push the
pawn we do have the rogue that can go
behind upon and now really what can't
like do how can black advance we can
also know that a kid doesn't really have
anywhere to help if the King tries to
move somewhere it cannot go too far away
because this route can always go back
and capture this pawn so we will go back
to this game but we don't think I don't
think neither me or erecting there's
gonna be something more interesting then
then a draw in couple moves so what else
we have here let's go to the game of the
tournament leader because we will have a
player of this game let me find a game
here we go so we have Benjamin back in
the studio welcome very good very nice
game but very peaceful or what can you
tell about it yeah so I prepared this
line but actually so there was a
preparation you think on the passive
side yeah because I played a g3 line
quite often so he sure had prepared it
he also played quite fast so most viñas
preparation so this was the first one
that you have to have to have to think
so you just decided to Castle looks like
natural move yeah you played Knight e4
and you're a I played this before looked
like a natural move to to me and okay
the position is symmetrical but I have
on extra tempo maybe I can do something
weirdest mm-hmm can you two go on c3 a
plate 96 yeah you're also considered to
play Queen v3 but also not sure he takes
e5 and if I take back takes takes maybe
Queen c7 because I thought if he plays
d6 I might have c4 and at the problem
the problem is that if he takes on c4 I
take on b7 and he always has to watch
out for a furnace Bishop can be trapped
so maybe there's a drawback of playing
Bishop a5 that the shop is no longer
defending the b7 square at the b7 pawn
but also it can go into some some
troubles like Benjamin said maybe before
where the bishop and you can get even
trapped yeah so okay I decided to take
on c6 but yeah what did you think here
did you thought you are just going for a
draw or did you try to push for some
advantage yeah I try to push a bit but
yeah if as you've told me that
apparently you were still in his
preparation okay I plays rook c1 rook c8
c4 and here Bishop e6 he told me that he
was still following in his analyzes it's
a very difficult to play a player who I
mean has such a deep analysis what is
your like advice to players who are
maybe worried about their opponents
being very well prepared
I shouldn't be too too worried and just
be well-prepared yourselves okay
so now he just played a line I didn't
know okay I took on d5 yes so take back
because okay if he takes for the bishop
in this position should be quite good
for me I play
III for example and I've worked c5
coming next
Brooks you want mm-hmm because suddenly
black has a weakness here and we can try
to like you said rook c5 Brooks you
wanna double all the power and try to
get the pawn for free yes so that's why
that's why I like to bid pawn yeah okay
and I have to take now on d7 didn't see
anything else he takes back and I
thought of a place to move like III he
plays d6 and like a dead wrong yeah I
don't see how I can be better okay do
you think there was like a key moment in
this game yeah I don't know maybe it was
all correct I don't know because he
prepared everything in the plate okay I
think here you had a couple of options I
was a bit surprised by Bishop age three
I thought he would take on d4 and here I
didn't see how to make use of the
bishops on the D foul for example if a
player rook cd1 he plays a five in case
of Bishop h6 he goes rook at the 8th and
if Bishop g5 rook a fate and I mean you
just make sure that off the e3 you can
move the bishop and if I take on a show
and you can take back with the rook
so if yes so they're small tactics of
the King cannot take because to be sure
but if your pre captures everything
looks fine yes and
I thought if I take on see it maybe he
can even take with the bishop because I
was quite curious our disposition was
let's a play rook d3
he plays a five and I don't know maybe
this is nonsense whoops okay I don't
know I'll just probably it should be
equal that so you have three points for
a bishop yeah it should be a draw but I
don't know who if if wise can be better
or not at all but and I thought that if
you place we should be fine
this could be in a Great Neck Road
because of c7 if it takes you a rookie
warrant maybe some problems we that's
interesting that even though the
material is equal it looks like it's
totally equal totally draw why I can
still put some advantage because we see
that the rooks are way more active than
the Blackhawks yeah of course I mean if
my initiative gets slowed down it's of
course a draw but if I can keep
something going on e yeah might still
have a small advantage mm-hmm Bishop h3
and a year I didn't see anything better
than Bishop g2 I thought if I play for
example ready one it takes on c1 I take
back with Bishop you play just to make
sure to defend the pawn on d4 and he
plays rook d8 and in case of E for yes
II 6
and if I go something like we should be
three he takes here and try Bishop III
but he takes place a six and it's just
the wrong mm-hm
so that's why what happened Bishop g2
and it looked like you just traded
material it went to do an endgame to the
rook and game was there anything to to
do in the endgame well here I thought I
might be a bit better but I didn't see
how so he took on d4 I think rook D 1 is
critical move play Bishop e6 I thought
if he takes here I can okay maybe I can
also okay I finally if I take with the
bishop and he plays let's say rook c8 I
take taken I thought you might be a
little bit better
c7 G for you stood the rook on c7 is
passive yeah he's the best person I can
push here a bit and it's like probably
he should be able to make it row but
it's a little bit unpleasant I guess I
mean this is usually the position you
want to have with what you are just
pushing you are playing for two results
either you make a draw or maybe black
well after one hour one hour and a half
playing make an inaccuracy and you can
you can even win yeah so but I think he
played it quite accurate he played we
should be six okay I don't see anything
else in rook d7 I mean if I starts from
Bishop eight sexy takes here go through
the eight okay next place f6 and
and king of seven so that's why I played
rubies huh okay he took two cruciate
yeah I think bishops eight-six is the
only move basically because otherwise
you have to try to keep the king box in
but here he has be five quite an
important move because after if you
would play a six then he can never
[Music]
entangled his pieces and I think here he
is very passive and I don't know if the
rook is kind of tied to the back rank we
have to know that maybe for some weaker
players let's say if they want to go and
attack the pawns here blood has to be
careful about getting checkmated because
this bishop is very strong defending
these squares around the King yeah so I
thought that I had some chances here but
I played Bishop c5 I think it was this
was quite accurate and here I don't see
how to do anything but a four but I
think maybe a six would have been even
more Icarus here so what's the idea of a
six because no Bishop e3 is not a move
anymore because the rook is not anymore
attacking the pawn and well if I play
King f3 he goes are six and he just
wants to play king of seven bring the
King finally looking at some freedom to
get away from those majors nets yes
yeah I don't see how I can how I can do
anything here he brings the king in it
should be a draw so he played f6 I think
Bishop III was good
it took took okay if you place a six
here I can take it goes rook c4 I go
rookie six he takes I take on f6 and
here I might have some chances because
he plays let's say a five I move the
rook here let's say move the rook I can
cut the King on it from the seventh rank
and if he pushes this pawn maybe I can
bring my king in front of my pawns and
it's not so easy I think because I
because I go with my king and he can you
can you can always win one pawn but I
always keep one so and finally compared
to your game you are kind of very happy
that this pawn doesn't have any points
that are blocking it here and the King
and the pawns both can kind of walk and
try to try to promote or maybe go for
some checkmates on the back rank yes so
I think a five was good from your side
played route d5 okay it became three is
normal king of seven is normal
I thought he for us basically the only
thing I can do because if I bring the
King I don't see how okay maybe I could
have tried to bring the King but I
thought that yeah
he also brings a game so I thought you
for was interesting because if you place
let's say King e6 I go Ruby 5 and if he
passes Brooke 87 for example maybe I can
try a 5 if he takes a looking efore
maybe some some chance of cell you can
being happy to break through there get
some space on the clear side for the
King to may be getting into the 8 7 yeah
just getting rid of my double pawn and
yeah I think I can try but I think Ruby
age was quite good from here it's gonna
be five you gave a check I think I have
to play III because if Akopian if to
probably just place rook before so III
okay now my king is a little bit stuck
but in this position maybe I should have
tried g4 to prevent my King from getting
completely locked in so the we are
looking with Erica this position we
thought it's a very good defensive idea
for forever safe to go rootbeer to
sacrifice the phone but make sure his
rook is active when we wondered if route
goes let's say to rook a to how black is
gonna how is white gonna get the King
out of the Kings
yeah I cannot get my King out the only
thing I was hoping for is that in some
position where I go rook eight and a
seven
I just show it so if you go let's say
you're okay eight and let's say you do
reach this pawn gets all the way to to
here
yeah maybe at some point I'll give up
this pawn for one of his pawns on the
King side and try to
[Music]
to make use of my extra pawn there yeah
I think g4 would have been a better try
because if he plays sorry here g4 yeah
if he goes g5 I might have a 5 and
points if he takes takes if you know it
takes on a four I think this end game
could be quite unpleasant so there's a
transposition you want if you wanted to
still keep the pawn but maybe this time
I'm keeping you on the kingside and I'm
still trying to to see if I can with the
extra pawn yes and okay if he if you
wait to the bouquet - I go h4 and yeah
if you go through well there was another
line it I thought 35 he goes rook a - I
take take and I give a check okay if he
goes okay maybe if he goes to e6 I play
h3 so after rock h2 I can take here
maybe he just plays h6 and it it must be
it's wrong okay so so what happened so
let's get the mouse here
so it looked like you you happen to have
this position probably there is nothing
else to do in this final position right
yeah the only thing yes watch out for is
not play King g7 in this position
because now I play a seven and I think
this is kind of a Chuck's fun for
example he plays King eight seven and
now I have rook F eight and here again
maybe it's still draw if you place
rookie seven for example he's but I can
maybe maybe bring the King around just
to explain to the funk it's like when
you have disadvantage of a move where
you have to play so in this situation
let's say you play King F seven which
would be a very very big mistake black
white can actually move the rook here
and now black is unable to take the pawn
because there will be a skewer here yes
exactly so that's why black would
probably have to go to eight seven but
then lose another pawn and there would
be there will be many many moves el else
in this game and a lot of fight now I
have a question Benjamin you won't yes
very very important game today you draw
the leader of your tournament what are
your thoughts about this tournament last
three games ahead yeah I started not so
good I started with 1-1 but of course
winning yesterday is it's quite
important to get back on 50% as soon as
possible also for your mood during the
tournament and well I was hoping to put
some pressure today but I think fuzzy
played quite precise and well I hope I
get some chances in the last three games
and last question how do you motivate
yourselves when you have maybe not a
perfect start and then you do want to
make that point you want to score so you
have you have a bright future in the
tournament how do you do it yeah well
I've never really have problems with
motivation so
yeah I guess it's just important not to
get to to to get your mood down to be
too sad and just keep positive moods and
try to keep playing for the win instead
of trying to play to say for thank you
for the wise words so remember always
keep your mood up even if the tournament
is not going right thank you so much for
joining us here good luck for the rest
of the games and we'll show we will take
a very short break and then we'll be
back with Eric this August the best
chess players in the world are coming to
st. Louis for the grand chest tour st.
Louis rapid and blitz and Sinquefield
Cup tournaments will feature the world's
best right here in st. Louis st. Louis
chess club is celebrating its 10th
anniversary and these tournaments will
be a highlight you won't want to miss
for tickets and more information go to
st. Louis chess club org
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership vacation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
this August the best chess players in
the world are coming to st. Louis for
the grand chess tour
st. Louis rapid and blitz and
Sinquefield Cup tournaments will feature
the world's best right here in st. Louis
st. Louis Chess Club is celebrating its
10th anniversary and these tournaments
would be a highlight you won't want to
miss for tickets and more information go
to st. Louis chess club org
you
everyone to the 2018 summer chess
classic I'm International Master Eric
Rosen joined by woman's Grandmaster
taught to Abraham Ian after a nice
victory over Vladimir Bellis
congratulations Dante so we were looking
at the game and we saw that you got a
position that really suited your style
especially the the sharp aggressive
style in the middle game take us through
the opening this is something that you
prepared or we're expecting well he has
played this line several times so if
I've made b-52 64 that's a 386 by and
there was a game where his opponent one
quickly Bishop e3 like I did and he
played with Bishop g7 and 97 and he's
opponent at the same idea of Castle
queenside and then this exponent was
hanging and I thought it's an
interesting way of playing because you
know when you're playing g6 Bishop g7 it
takes so long and d6 becomes a target so
I think it makes sense to immediately
try to take that pawn so you play Bishop
8 6 quickly so I'm assuming that
something he prepared to discuss you off
guard a little bit but then I started
calculating and I thought like I get to
develop very quickly this seems becomes
a target that castle and so I played 994
so I played after you keeping in mind
that I might still Castle queenside
because if I counsel Queen side I think
immediately there's Queen b6 enough to
hang because without my daughter squared
Bishop his queen is gonna try to
dominate or at least control the dart
squares so you're saying in this line if
you Castle queenside it could be a bit
problematic for white yeah no no I don't
have that Bishop 23 so I want to make
sure the Queen doesn't get in
that's very true so I played f3 I'm not
hiding my intentions of castling
queenside set castles it seemed like you
could you got everything you could ask
for out of the opening I mean safe safe
King and some nice King side attack yeah
I mean I think it one Castle opposite
side pawn on c4 I think my king is
fairly safe because with the pawn
hanging on d6 he can never go really be
5 because 36 and night hangs
and that's riot and it's common in these
structures at d6 was just such a
long-term weakness and maybe not the
best opening choice given what happened
to black and middlegame well I think you
should have played Queen D so yeah I
don't think you should cancel because so
in this position and castling is maybe a
bit too risky
yeah I think you should've played Queen
d8 or I don't know maybe Quinn did
before instead of 97 mm-hmm just not the
happiest move to play just putting your
peace Queen g5 also is a question
whether it wants to be there or not
right that is true so if you can't play
quickly Queen d7 room d8 because 96 is
not hanging yeah
what's c5 be possible for white here
kind of most come in a 94 could be nice
if I take them b5 95 maybe hangs I don't
know so maybe some complex deviations to
what happened in the game aged 6 now
heating screen goes back 94 takes b5
yeah so Queen goes back maybe to e3 yeah
but yeah I don't I don't like this trade
at all I feel like I'm letting my
opponents miss is that that's very true
I don't want so one weakness for white
in the in the center of the board this
d4 square so let's actually take a look
at what happened the game because it
seemed like it was just in your comfort
zone
at what point did you feel like you had
the advantage well I would I played it
right that like I didn't yeah it's
actually funny because after 96 that's
knife there were 36 you go back if he
goes 95 I think I can play in c6 and go
before oh wow that's simple tactics and
you're your king stay safe right yeah I
mean I have all these pieces and one
Bishop is not getting 10 things I can
always fake Queen e3 and my King goes
gonna be saved yes here I'm just up upon
and his king is just kind of alone and
he's not gonna because the Knights nc6
is hanging there is no attack would be 5
or anything and even if you played b5 I
don't know what your follow-up is but if
you play b5 before and take on a - I'm
just gonna take a while and I just feel
like my king is just as much safer and
your your attack comes much quicker on
the King side it's like you win material
you have a
common say SH and you have initiative it
seems like everything went right for you
in this game yeah I don't know if
actually thought maybe I could have
taken on this seven and they played 95
but I don't think that was necessary if
you're a material yeah I think my attack
is just crushing mm-hmm
so already maybe around this point you
you felt pretty good about your position
yeah here I was just thinking like I
need to have a crushing way of playing
and I just like I had so many options I
didn't know what to play of course yeah
so let's zoom through cuz the finish was
pretty nice I mean like black King kind
of walked all the way across the board
yeah I mean here yeah because now my
bishop gets in the game so the game is
over yeah he did fight on for perhaps a
long time but not too much hope for
black and especially around here it's
just completely one-sided and the finish
is nice we should note after King a for
their force made here for White Queen
this event
mp3 and King have the final position
with opposition among the teams so nice
finish so I believe this is your first
win of the tournament what's it been
like for you being the lowest seed in
the vent how you been able to maybe cope
with not the best not the best
performance but so a lot of fighting
games well I'm gonna I'm performing over
my rating good thing I'm performing
around 2500 if achill tournament it's
always it's actually very nice to be the
lowest seed because the pressure is on
your opponent I think the trust that
I've made have been like I've been on
the better side of the game again my
first round and against Robert yesterday
I was on a better side my most
heartbreaking game was against Camille
when I had me and the reason is is
because the mistake that I made was so
typical of the mistakes that I usually
make which is what really it's not
necessary right this B 5 me yeah because
you know I didn't build a fortress and
it's already draw like he told me like
and I mentally was ready to make a draw
and then instead of just you know
keeping the game the same way it just
had to go for something forcing and try
to force the matters and of course I
forgot that yeah then
and I thought I'm just forcing to dry
instead of just going to pack on Ford
and the game is already dry so that's
what I'm upset about because I feel like
this is the kind of mistake I make a lot
otherwise you know playing a grandmaster
every round it's really difficult but
it's very enjoyable because it's not
every day I get to do this for sure and
you know who you played tomorrow I'm
playing black tomorrow you want to stand
playing mm-hmm any thoughts on that game
he has not lost a single game so far
this tournament that he's suffering
today right is he suffering yes
suffering I flayed him before I was
white and it was very like I was on the
losing side and I barely drew that
that's my I'm gonna be blocks I'm sure
he's gonna try put some pressure I mean
I'll very nice I won't keep you any
longer
especially towards the end of the
tournament and you have to I mean get to
sleep early conserve energy because
especially these later games they are
tough yeah
best of luck in your later rounds thank
you and we're gonna get back to the
analysis here we do have a result in
group a between Jeffrey Zhang and Sam 7
Sam actually managed to win the position
in a crazy tactical battle it's been a
while since we last looked at this
position let's see let's see how it see
how this game transpired going back here
Jeffrey did sack material relatively
early sacking the exchange on the
queenside
and it seemed like he just didn't get
anything for the material deficit if we
go back to this position after a queen
f2 seems like Sam just defended
everything rook t2 and 94 good good
harmony in the center with the rook on
d2 hitting the Queen Queen on c3 knight
on d4 and box pieces just don't seem
coordinated here Queen h4 was played and
really it just seemed like a matter of
technique for Sam having maximum
material this nylon a3 we should note as
is just trapped in the position and
after a queen f2 maybe going for some
last tricks where whites queen is tied
down to the finding the knight on d4 Sam
played the very simple Queen B 2 and
after the trade seems like it's just a
matter of technique
and Sam is now in I believe clear second
place after this victory actually tied
for second I'm being told and with that
I'm joined now by Catarina and Sylva
welcome back Catarina thank you so far
yes I think we have amazing games we
have even decisive results I'm always
happy to see to see decisive results so
what do we go to game yaro share a book
or Inazuma bf I thought it was another
game that promises decisive resolved
this was a game we were looking at
earlier and we should note that both
players are playing relatively quickly
given that they still have a few more
moves to make before move for the
position seems to be heating up a few
more moves have been played after rook
take a seven and I take e7 this brings
us to the current position where it
seems like light is just stuff a clean
pot and another ponies hanging on h5
this just looks like what is having no
trouble I think you're always having
huge advantage here yeah I would not be
too happy in black situation and if I'm
not mistaken I don't think yaro has won
a game this event he started off with
with so many draws and then lost the
game if I'm not mistaken yesterday so if
he can win this game maybe he's uh he's
gonna have some momentum going into the
final rounds yes and he would be back at
50% he says that drawers are good so 50%
he is happy to be back so we're gonna go
back to dance to this game what about
Peter Prohaska and Baraka beyond game is
a draw do they still try to play for win
I think it's the only other game going
on in Group A and I mean we still have
to prefer white given that white just
has a better pawn structure black having
to pawn islands this rook on a6 be
incredibly passive and completely tied
down to defending this pawn on d6 so
it's everything to play for
as as white in this position
okay so let's move on to tournament P we
have the leader polish grandmaster cameo
dragon playing with Turkish Grand Master
JJ Alomar on D JT had some issues there
are some problems some passing Bischoff
how it looks now they pass the 40 moves
so they both have extra 30 minutes so it
looks like now it's when they gonna take
a break and think it's very possible but
it seems like white is just making a lot
more progress we can see that especially
this this F pawn very stable on f6 in
the heart of blacks position and I mean
it seems like JJ could could suffer
another defeat this tournament that's
true so what about a last round in
tournament B Josh Trudel against Robert
a Kesari on George had some problems
here as well yeah we were looking at
this game earlier and we were very much
preferring blacks position it seems like
black is still for choice being just up
a clean pawn again terrible pawn
structure for what for whites given
White has all isolated pawns these
double pawns on the a file not so
impressive and I'm still waiting for
this maneuver from Robert getting the
Capablanca Knights but maybe there's
some other potential maybe he wants to
find a way to attack this week pawn on
g6 maybe he's considering some idea like
ninety six and nine f4 I agree I'm just
thinking what is a good space what is
what is a good square for the bishop on
d3 because if the knight gets to d6 I
mean but I guess everything like an
desire I can't be happy being Josh in
this position it is Roberts move so if
we if we just maybe ponder here what to
play actually ninety six has been played
and we can see Robert they're getting up
from his seat Josh can't be too happy
with this Knight about to land on f4
hitting the the bishop on d3 hitting the
pawn on g6 might just be a matter of
technique before Robert can can scoop up
the pawn on g6 maybe put the King on d6
seems like the momentum is really going
for black yes I want to say something at
least positive for white I thought it
may be that the black pawns are
Squyres v7c 65 maybe in a bishop can go
around so what if I go they should be
I mean rookie to rugby to right now
force you to go to defend upon now you
have to pick if you're gonna defend it
with a knight or with the rook it's
actually a good point black does have
perhaps this uh this undefended pawn and
b7 it's one of the only weaknesses for
lack in the position and it is a
question how does black defend the pawn
because a move like ninety eight or rip
be eight it doesn't seem that preferable
yeah if you play a rook b8 I can go look
up to and now my idea is to go to the
rook F seven and maybe do some do
something there attack the pawn on g7 or
or just talk like for making any
advancement I'm sure I'm sure Robert
would not be happy going for some sort
of repetition with the rooks mirroring
each other between the B and the F files
we can see Josh has but has played rook
to be to putting the question how does
black actually play for a win here I
absolutely agree I would like to move on
back maybe do tournament a but which
game so there's not too many games going
on in term in a not sure if we have a
graphic but there are a number of games
done this round with the saved are
Bailey drawing Benjamin Bach maybe we
don't have a graphic but we can I can
scroll through oh there's a graphic so
two pending games with Benjamin jukebox
drawing the sea star Bailey Sam seven
this is a big game of the round
defeating Geoffrey Jean moving into a
tie for second place
and Daniel Friedman drawing Alexander in
judge so two games left in Group A
between Peter Paris go against Park
Markovian and euros Arabic against
Renata Mathias now what about the
graphics for Group B there are also many
decisive games we see the dinner Rosario
Casas won again Alejandra Ramirez sorry
I'm a thinker drew with Andres took
talking and thought of Abraham an won
again against Val you know bellows we
have two large game pending that's a
good day for the ladies to decisive
games and it seems like maybe there's
some some energy happening in the later
stage of the tournaments
maybe maybe there's a start for them and
two more
we'll bring more points so let's go back
to the game between Camille dragon and
jayjay a lemur Andy cuz this is a very
important game for the standings in
Group B if Camille can win this game
hold extend his lead and and give JJ his
first loss of the tournament and I like
his both Queen a 7 we were thinking
about attacking the king maybe pushing
the pawn in points in the center but
come on it's like I'm fine with my pawns
I have advantage on the Kings side I'm
just gonna grab as many pawns as I can
on the Queen side I really like this
move between a7
I mean White's King side incredibly
solid everything defended and meanwhile
okay two pawns are attacked black can't
defend both of them why not just go pawn
grabbing and get more material like now
we'll have to try to you know move I
mean it's probably lost position so he
will just try to you know give
everything but he and so maybe g4 just
to try to I mean yeah when you're when
you're playing black in these positions
is there's nothing to lose I mean you
have the disadvantage you're expected to
lose so the strategy is that you want to
make it as crazy as possible
try and create some complications given
that okay you're down material and maybe
we'll see some potential sacrifices g4
certainly being a candidate move just
trying to open up more lines on the
Kings side but it seems like white very
simply respond with a move like f4 yeah
so that's why jayjay decided to play
rook c8 maybe just let's defend this 7th
rank let's defend the pawn on c7 so he
played rook c8 waiting with you know
some ideas like g4 and thinking what
else can he do the here at Roxy it seems
like a very depressing move I mean when
you have to move a rook to defend the
pawn which is useless in the position
you're you probably know that things are
going wrong I wouldn't be surprised if
if Camille just picks up the free pawn
on e6 I mean why not and it's still a
question how is black creating any
active play in this position we can
imagine that the Queen would love to
somehow get to a better square sometimes
when I when I'm in positions like this
and my pieces are just kind of not on
the best squares I would I would like to
imagine where they're best placed and
this position I would love to bring the
Queen's
how to f1 but it seems like it would
take many moves so might be some idea
like Queen f7 Queen b3 Queen d1 Queen f7
we can be very creative here kind of
like a maze trying to get to the desired
location of course if this work bughouse
it would be a lot easier to a strip your
partner for a queen and then maybe if I
could get some initiative it's a very
sad position white is just grabbing most
likely under pawn black is suffering
let's move on to a different game this
is too sad so let's move back to group a
because there's some excitement taking
place in the battle between yarrow Zahra
book and Renacci mabye of seems like
yarrow is on his way to converting the
advantage and a pretty pretty nice
sacrifice if I'm not mistaken if we go
back a few moves the players have
reached move 40 yard we'll grab the free
pawn in H 5 and after g6 he played the
very bold Bishop take g6 is this a piece
sacrifice or is it just as it a winning
combination I mean it looks like black
will recapture the bishop and then I
think another pawn on c6 and then g6 is
hanging I mean I may end up having five
points for for a knight
while we have to keep in mind that the
King is so we there are no points in
front of him to defend it so white has
many ideas of actual checkmating the
game this is so painful to look at from
from the backside I mean the the five
pawns for the knight is the least of
blacks worries while the King is just so
naked on g8 Queen g6 would becoming
queen take g6 check and queen take t5
check both threats in the position maybe
we could analyze a few moves further
given that 97 perhaps the only logical
move and then probably the very simple
Queen e6 check you want to get a closer
to the King we are attacking tonight as
well
I'm just winning back material I mean
King f8 is just very simply Queen f6
King g8 or of take a 7 this should be
decisive very soon for yaro
this game maybe this can can be over
very soon
soul asking we didn't look at or we did
but not too much
Peter Prohaska and Baraka beyond
yeah maybe we can spend a bit more time
here trying to figure out if White has
anything to play for in the game
given that var is the is in close behind
I believe he's currently tied with Sam
Savion for second place in Group A and
if far loses this game that could really
really allow the thief to run away with
what the tournament lead but I don't see
a plan how to how to advance here I mean
how do you want to create anything here
for for white maybe you want to define
the pawn on d3 coming back with King e2
and forcing the black rook on d5 to go
into passive square on d6 that's very
true especially with the last move III
both both of these ideas kini too but
also this just very simple move pawn to
d4 creating kind of the mini launching
for white could be a stabilizing idea
and meanwhile white does want to
consider just grabbing the pawn on d6
I'm a little bit curious Peter was able
to just grab the pawn right here with a
move like rook take b6 but I'm wondering
if he thought the sign wouldn't give him
enough money chances yes I mean rook and
games pawn up does not always mean that
the endgame is gonna be won so
grandmasters probably understood that
Black has many chances to defend this
position so Peter wants to maybe make
extra weaknesses and get extra advantage
before grabbing that pawn I think this
is a very good practical situation
because I mean at Grand Master level
these these three versus four positions
they typically end with a with a draw
though maybe if you're magnus carlsen
maybe you can grind it out so i think
peter made a good decision delaying
capturing the weak pawn on d6 maybe
trying to make some improving moves get
far low on time and then when the moment
is right take the pawn later when VAR
has less time to actually calculates so
what do you think let's move on to a
different game or do you want to stay
here a little longer we can maybe stay
here just a bit longer we see that that
Varis thinking in the position both
players silhouetted there on on the
video
yeah he I mean var is notorious for
getting lower low on time and in this
game he could he could exhaust all his
time given that's there's only one
moment where you get more time in the
game so I'm wondering does black just
have to wait here or is there any any
way of maybe simplifying the position
for black I mean I also want to know
that there started to play at 1:00 p.m.
so it's soon gonna be four hours of
playing so black is very tired so maybe
white want to take advantage of that and
really try to push for something and
make vara tired even more and maybe
force him to make inaccuracies that's a
good point we do have one more move
played a somewhat unexpected move rook a
to but maybe it's very logical making
the worst one of the most passive pieces
ever on a6 a much more active piece on
the second-ranked
completely forgetting about the pawn and
if we imagine that that white takes the
pawn maybe Black has some idea of
coordinating the rooks perhaps rook c5
and rook c2 and we might see this 3 on 4
scenario which could be a very long
grinding game I agree another idea can
be instead of a rook c5 rooks he - maybe
we can play rogue DT oh and for the D
pawn to even push more and then we have
some chances of even changing it by
playing E 5 but I I wouldn't want to
play this position for black being
pulled down and suffering that's always
difficult for the further side that has
the last material it's a very good point
I think vara is gonna have to undergo
some some long a long torture through
this game if he wants to hold on for the
half points but that's what that's what
grandmasters do or have to do sometimes
they have to defend where it's end games
and because there's so much so much
money on the line given the tournament
situation
I know var is is gonna be fighting until
until every last move in this game I
would like to move on to the Josh
Friedel game against Robert agus re on
the rook is moving to B 2 2 h2 trying to
create some some active space
so we'll do what do we think about is
yeah when we last left we saw the move
rook b2 played hitting the pawn on b7
and I'm pretty sure that Robert probably
turned down this rook b8 move because of
your idea rook f2 so that's why he opted
for maybe the more solid 98 but it's a
little bit slow and as a game continued
rook h2 king d6 it's still a question
for for black how to activate the
Knights and keep the pawn on b7 defended
but for the time being it seems like
white just has to wait around and black
is having all the fun yes so not much is
happening in these games players have a
lot of time so we would like maybe to
promote the rapid and blitz tremendous
ahead of us that's a good point
for the second year in a row we have two
very exciting events in August from
August 6 from August 9th through the
16th we have the st. Louis rapid and
blitz 2nd edition and I know last year
was very exciting I was actually here in
st. Louis Kasparov came out of
retirement for the events I don't think
he's returning this year but I'm sure
there's gonna be a lot of strong players
and we also have the single stuff coming
up that's an amazing tournament I think
I always enjoy watching the commentary
watching the players I was here actually
three times for a sink filled gap
it's amazing how to how to chess scene
here just changes with so many strong
grandmasters being here no it's
incredible like here you walk down the
Central West End and you you throw a
rock and you hit a grandmaster rated
over 2700 so it's just such an
incredible experience just being here in
person and I'm sure there will be a lot
of people traveling from all over the
country if not all over the world to
watch the event and it's totally worth
it I think they always pay amazing games
and it's just great to see these players
fight against each other it's true I do
want to go back and show a moment from
earlier today it was actually the first
game not finished but I think we should
at least go back and give the viewers
some some instructive moments from that
game do you happen to know which game I
might be referring to do you mean
Daenerys Ibaka Sawa against Alejandra
Ramirez that's that's very true that was
um maybe not
Alejandro's best day at the office going
down very quickly almost a miniature
losing in in just over 25 moves and I do
want to show the game given that dinara
seemed very well prepared in the opening
and she was able to seize initiative
from very early on so Alejandro played
his maybe someone expected a 6 B 6 we
saw him play this earlier in the
tournament with not great success
against Vladimir Bellis it's very
interesting that is opening started as a
very peaceful game and suddenly I mean
the the game was over in in less than 30
moves
that's true and dinara showed no fear
just going for the the pretty early
central expansion if we see this pawn
move on d5 completely blocking out the
Bishop on b7 and after c5 was played she
expanded even further with f4 now I do
want to zoom forward to the very
instructive moment after Knight g6 was
played she unleashed a really powerful
and and very aesthetic idea here given
that she has so much space in the center
why not expand you
further and why not target one of lacks
biggest weaknesses in the position this
pawn on e6 she played the beautiful move
pawn f5 which maybe you don't see every
day
such pawn structure from so early on in
the opening and it looks like
so I hundred took on f5 so if white
recaptures pawn takes f5 the knight has
amazing square on e5 and black has
nothing to worry about
but dinara had an amazing idea that does
not block in this position yeah she
played maybe a nice subtle pawn
sacrifice pawn to e5 with a very direct
tactical idea of winning the Queen just
threatening Bishop take out five so we
really have to admire Daenerys tactical
resourcefulness in this line the game
continued pretty in a pretty ugly manner
for Alejandro needing to get the King to
a safer place
King ba played but after Bishop take a
five white just keeps initiative and in
like one material in just a few more
moves yeah I don't know how much time
you want to spend on this game knowing
that Alejandro he's home here this is
even his studio almost so let's just
quickly see what happened Alejandro will
not be happy thus reviewing it but it is
a very instructive moment for for all
those watching seeing how a very strong
Grandmaster can go down with what seemed
like not much of a fight yeah it's I
mean when we see the bishop on b7 the
knight on e5 those key those pieces are
just out of the game these don't have
any future and we did interview
alejandro after his win over vladimir
bellows a few days ago and he said he he
kind of forgot how to play chess that
game i wonder if this game was no
different and of course in this game he
was severely punished for it it must be
also very difficult for him he's a coach
he's a player he's working here at a
chess club he has so many chest
responsibilities so just being an active
player it may be a very difficult
situation to really be able to play your
best game every single game that's true
but I mean that's the thing about being
a high level chess player I mean this
happens to everyone everyone has rough
days where you don't play your best
chess I'm sure I mean it's happened to
me many times I'm sure it's happened to
you
how do you deal with the game like this
how do you bounce back for the the later
rounds yeah I liked what Benjamin Bloch
was suggesting in my interview I was
asking him even like how you know how to
keep your mood up and you are not having
a great tournament and he was just like
you just have to you just have to have
your mood up so you can play well so I
think that's a very good message that's
what I also try to to do in mind games
my game is thinking like okay maybe this
is not the best game I have to move on
tomorrow is the next day a new game I
just have to perform well now that's
very true I think it's a matter of
discipline but it's also a matter of
mindset where you don't necessarily want
to be too worried on the result I mean
with as a chess player as a high-level
chess competitor you want to be thinking
long-term and you want to be thinking
about how you'll develop over the coming
months and years and one event of course
is not the end of the world so so what
if we go back to the game yarrow
cherrybrook is still playing against
three not you my wife so the game is not
yet over did he miss something or is it
gonna be over soon looks like black got
some type of counter play we may have
overlooked to move yeah after Queen
takes c6 I was expecting the very
passive 97 but Ranaut went for the much
more active rookie 2 but after a king f3
it doesn't seem too promising for black
given that both the Knights heroic not
to mention the pawn on g6 are all
undefended it just seems pretty much
over for for for black in this position
yeah this is a very difficult situation
we see tonight it's extra night but
oh he's not he just played rookie three
is there any chance for some kind of
purpose rocky 3 does it is one more
check but after king f2 I think black is
out of checks though he did play another
move rook e 2 is this some sort of
desperation or is there a plan behind
behind it
I mean can white just simply take the
rook so then probably the only movies
just queen e8 just hoping to create a
cooperation between the knight and queen
but we can have anything we can play
even King f1 I think this is just
desperate and this is what's being
it out queenie 8 was played and I do
like the the very safe King f1 there
would be one more check in the position
93 but after King gg1 it just seems over
for for is it is it already over no he's
still thinking but no it's gonna be over
forever not very soon so before we wrap
it up let's have the last glance at the
game of cameo dragon and JJ Ali Morandi
is that game over or is there a chance
for black to defend
I mean JJ is still under very serious
pressure Kamil dragon expanding even
further rook ghs played oh we see Mike
comer they're putting the Kings in the
center of the board looks like yaro has
has officially won his game first
victory of the tournament four yards
arabic again a very good return
yesterday he has had first lost today he
he has first win so it's great to see
how he just got back to the tournament
so maybe we can have pairings for
tomorrow or standings what is happening
in the tournament a we have many results
already actually we're going to hold off
on that for a moment and wait for the
graphic to be prepared but let's let's
take a look at this game because after
Brooke g8 and black is maybe employing
the the cocoon mechanism he's just
trying to hold on for dear life as white
continues to expand and we see this very
very aesthetic move just played pawn f5
cementing oops
cementing the very beautiful pawn chain
all on light squares restricting the
black bishop on g7 doesn't seem too
pretty for black yeah that's what let's
not spend too much time now I have an
information that the graphic is ready so
let's see what is the what is the
standing of group a right we have
received our Bailey maintaining his lead
and the version the Cobian games still
going on if version can hold a draw
he'll be only a half point behind first
place but if Pierre bergé osku kick
comes through with the win then the seat
will be leading the tournament by full
points
so what about pairings for tomorrow for
group a oh there is a correction in that
graphic which were not did lose his game
well let's take a look at pairings for
tomorrow Alexander in judge against
Benjamin Bach Jeffrey Zhang against
Daniel Friedman Renata mabye of against
Sam seve and who is making a comeback
and fighting for some of the top places
of course we also have version of Cobian
against yarrow jariabek and tournament
leader of Vasavada bailey playing his
Webster teammates Peter Piroska I'm
wondering if that's going to be a hard
fought game or maybe a peaceful draw and
it's gonna be curious especially to see
how Peter plays today we devour because
if Peter is able to win that rügen game
then he's ready to to be you know to try
to win against us if so that's very true
it's all about momentum and if you can
have maybe a maybe a lucky win it can
give you some energy and motivation
going forward in the tournament so let's
see the trauma and B what is what is a
standing there now we still have a
couple games still pending
Camille dragon leading the tournament if
he if he draws or wins his game he'll be
still in clear first and of course not
still not the best tournament for
Vladimir Bellis losing to talkto Abraham
you and today they're a very difficult
tournament very difficult start for him
three more rounds to go well let's see
how he's gonna do so let's see what is
the pairings for tomorrow we have Robert
Alcazar Ian against dinara sadaqa Silva
Braga Mirabella against Josh free del JJ
Alima Randy playing with Tata Abraham
iam and race took open against camel
dragon and Alejandro Ramirez against her
game at Cinco especially in the later
rounds sometimes we'll see players get
tired we might have to expect more
blunders but certainly a lots lots more
exciting chess ahead of us
I'm really happy with this drama and
seeing so many very really interesting
games a lot of tactics even positional
and games
I see how players are happy to have
their spotlight to have nice tournament
great price and I think all of them are
enjoying this tournament that's right
I'm joying it myself just watching the
games lots of excitement and I'm sure
there's a lot more excitement to come
join us tomorrow grounds
Evan starts at 1:00 p.m. and you can
follow all the games live on us chess
champs calm looking forward to another
exciting day of chess see you tomorrow
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you